To create our awesome apps,
you need to design great UIs.
And to integrate these
Uis with your code
and create a nice
user experience,
you need to write a
lot of code, right?
Hi, I'm Neto Marin, and I'm here
to introduce the Data Binding Library
and help you
write less code.
With Data Binding, you can move
base UI Logic code from Java
to your XML layout code.
So no more findViewById
or setText
calls to manipulate and
update your layouts.
And the good news is
that the Data Binding
is a support library.
So you can use it with all
Android platform versions
back to Android
2.1 or API Level 7.
The Data Binding Library
is already available under
the support repository,
through
the Android SDK Manager.
And don't forget to check if
you're using Android Studio 1.3
or later.
For more details about Gradle
dependency, classpath and
Android Studio plugin configuration,
visit the Data Binding
Guide on developer.android.com
and check all the steps
and configuration.
Now let's see how Data Binding
can help you write less code.
Imagine you want
to show some user
information, like first
name, last name, and email.
Your layout XML file,
without Data Binding
could look like this.
And then you will have to
implement a bunch of Java code
to instantiate the
views, find the views,
and set the correct values.
But now with Data
Binding, you just
have to add a
data tag declaration
with the variable name and type.
And for each view, when you
want the data from the object,
just refer to the
corresponding attribute.
All the data will be
retrieved from the data object
that you declared and populated.
This data object could be
a plain old Java object,
a POJO for that
user, or it's also
possible to use a
JavaBean object.
Much easier, eh?
And to bind events,
it's straightforward as well.
Bind events to
handler methods directly,
similar to what you
do using
android: onClick when assigning
to a method in the activity.
But now let's move
on a more complex UI,
like this fictional news app.
Notice several details, like
a different color for read
and unread news or headline
colors for breaking news.
This would require quite a few
lines of code to implement.
And again, Data Binding can
make your life easier here.
For example, here we
have the layout file
for the items of the news
app, each news.
And you can see how we
moved the logic of changing
the CardView's
background color, to red
or white, to one attribute
of the news item class.
And moving the logic
from the adapter to the XML
makes the adapter much
simpler, as we can see here.
In this example, we just need
to create the NewsItemBinding
and inflate it.
And the great thing here
is that the NewItemBinding
was automatically generated
by the Data Binding Library.
So, for example, if you have
a layout file called news_item.xml
the library will create the
NewsItemBinding automatically.
And after creating
and inflating,
you return this
into a ViewHolder.
And on onBindingViewHolder
is the place
where you state that a
specific ViewHolder is
bound to a specific item.
And here is a ViewHolder class.
As we can see, much simpler.
No more FindViewById,
no more ImageView,
or TextView, or whatever.
It's something you write once
and don't have to maintain.
You just have to change your
item layout, if you need,
and the library will
update all the stuffs.
It just works.
Another great benefit of using
Data Binding are the custom attributes
You can define some
custom attributes,
like imageURL, that
actually doesn't exist,
but you can develop it using
some third-party library.
Or a color filter option,
which you can do easily
with a few line of codes.
So after adding the custom
attributes to the XML Layout file
you have to code, wherever
you want, a public static method
and add the notation
@BindingAdapter
to have that method, bound to
that custom attribute.
And you have no more
to add listeners
and all the stuff you need
to perform a specific action.
You will no longer
need to do FindViewById
any place in your code.
For example, if you have an item
in your layout with the id mark_read,
the library automatically
generates a field
inside the binding class.
And also, if your pojo implements
the Observable interface
descends from
BasicObserver, when
you call a setter on that
POJO, like this setIsRead
to mark this item as
read, any UI views
in your layout that rely on
that attribute will be updated.
Another nice trick you
have with Data Binding
is that you can use an
operators, in this case,
a null check.
So if the other
attribute is null, you
can use any other
string you want.
Check the documentation for
the handful of other operators
that can simplify your code.
And also, you can include
another layout file
and specify an attribute bound
for you with this layout.
In summary, Data Binding makes
your code shorter, simpler,
and easier to maintain.
Check out the Data Binding Guide
for details, configurations,
and more about this new library.
Looking forward to see you
make your code simpler.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]